4.36 to be exact and they have been firing at all
cylinders one other team hitting at four two on
one Sosi brings it in Sosi fanned on it and then
a weak one on Smith little Pat in the back right
there Trevor lowski that says you've got a shot
too big man don't be afraid to use it one goal
two points on the season thus far for slowski
Evans using the boards svich dumps it back in
for rapel Harvey penard Harvey penard watched by
Hughes Evans space shoots up top high bouncing
pucking the Smith got the shoulder on it Readiness
to shoot when he took the D'Or drop pass listen
nobody like killing penalties more than you Dave
and you must have love that effort last night in
the third no question about it it's the subtle
little things I like about Christian D'Or game
Jacky backs him up works it deah hand S kovski
at the end of a shift he'll change Harris for
Pearson space opening up Pearson off the post
followup try have a little chot with himself
space opened up shot opened up and bang Hughes
on the puck the captain trying to spin away from
mat two great skaters Hughes up top sudor wrist
shot and Allen hasn't been that busy thus far in
this first period he'll squeeze in his seventh
game of the season Heron thought about the one
timer he'll work it in Deep liler Fishing for
it as he came over in the B Horvat trade from
the New York Islanders former first round
pick Luger frees it up up top Heron accepts
the pass Heron R shot through traffic and it
squeak through Allen but right to Monahan he
tried to thread that to space Pearson on the
buck over the line knocked off his stick and
the Canucks in transition quickly led by bili
drops to pluger R shot gly another block and
that stung him I think the puck stung him off the
stick might have hit him in the head area but gly
appears to be okay and quick drive hurry panar
off the rebound trying to steal one and get one
by to Smith another Puck from pizetta towards
theet pin balls to Harvey penard Harvey penard
G's got some space WR shot in out of the glove
Puck available and cleared as gly trying to go
back to back at the Bell Center it is going to
come if he continues with these opportunities
suder over the line with
Joshua sud wrist shot blocker
sto he'll flip the back end in there's JT
Miller quickly for Cole Quinn Hues threads
that through Center picked up in stride Miller
dish pass score beautiful tip in front Conor
Garland and it's one nothing Vancouver
the rink pass and then lays just a soft
back hand in so look at the hu dish across
Darin going to the net H Miller looks like
he's going to go back zov's got some looks
from some dangerous spots just hasn't be
able to cash dorak he wants up score Christian
dorak from the point Hales level the score at
one Vancouver is using their
coach's challenge to challenge
a play for offside prior to the goal R taka
taking advantage of the Nano break do some
coaching leore suakin Brandon garlets
don't take very long looking at this
one after reviewing the play please reset
the clock to 1217 the play was offside no
goal Suzuki chenel chip to Center and now
Allen can't get the stick yet as the Canucks
possess the buck the bre some space shoots
score Canucks take advantage ilam mcka beats
Allen with no stick helpless feeling and it's
two nothing Vancouver as he took the stick out
of the hands Allan can't get back there and
it's a soft chip out in the neutral zone and
AA comes in and the realization that there's
no stick for Jake Allen he goes low with it
a very smart shot on a goal tender without a
stick just inside the post glove Allan thought
about going to try and get [Applause] it lonski
digs it free shot up top rebound right back at
dorak JBS away and Casey to Smith a few massive
stops dishes Garland stops WR shot kicked aside
by Allen heroni jams it back in Garland picks
it up walks it in front backhand try still lose
follow up Garland again rebound score Dakota
and Joshua cleans it up and it's three nothing
Vancouver just allowed for the coach's Challenge
on offside they came right back and made it to
nothing and they've continued to build on
it more and more play in the Montreal Zone
quick UPS by Vancouver wasting no time at
all to move the puck forward big Dakota
Joshua turn over Gallagher Edge space
gallager glove stop still loose comes
in picks it off but watch the little move
he makes right here to slip it through the
inside edges outside edges and the people
he's deceiving out there are guys named
Nick Suzuki who's a pretty good Defender and
just put him in his tracks Suzuki touch pass
Anderson driving in backand try and stop by
A Smith in all alone yes he's in all alone
three PR Monahan down low Anderson
backhand chance is still lose M shoots and
scores Mike m power play goal and the Hales
got one by the [Music] Smith unfortunately
the first penalty had just ended so they're
not going to still remain on the power play
Buton they got the marker a nice little touch
pass from Monahan look at the effort by Josh
Anderson in front of G's got a clows off some
real estate quickly and he does from Garland in
time Pearson the other way avoids the contact
Pearson in front oh what a chance Pearson to
Monahan and he just healed it a little bit
so back to back for the halves my goodness
Giger still not there kzo walks it in right in
front oh Alan one stop rebound available Jake
Allen save of the night and a delayed penalty
but watch the Saves by Jake [Applause] Allen
Suzuki in the puck battle look out bester space
cutting in and Allan SS with it another stop T
JPI the followup Rob by Allen Jake Allen
seventh game of the season he has been
Sensational all the way down to the Smith the
came to him Ned empty look out besser shoots
scores the dagger Brock besser 12th of the Season
as he's one of the top scorers in the National
Hockey League trying to chase down Austin Matthews
it's 41 Vancouver in front of the net sha monan
had a stick on it third period on hockey fights
cancer I here at the Bell Center the Knox trying
to put the wraps on their three-game road trip of
the victory Arbor Jacky brings it in shoots score
Arbor Jacky a late strike we're not done yet 4-2
kuu a good time there within two walks in get his
stick gets his stick free watch right there just
picks his stick where where he's going pulls it
back and beats to Smith on the short side po
25 seconds left around the boards picked up
by besser he takes a look finds JT Miller net
available Miller dppi [Applause] scores third
of the season for Philip D jppy and that should
be the dagger here on this Sunday night in this
all Canadian battle 52 kuu Helen and obviously
two empty Nets at the end DJ steppi finishing
this off in the unselfish play he gave it away
to Joshua and that'll do it so the Vancouver
canu wrap up their pregame road trip on a high
note rebounding from the lawon run last night